[Musique]
on veut avoir la vie de christiane
bergevin de claire bolduc sur ce grand
sujet du troisième ligne et bonsoir
mesdames bonsoir bonsoir alors clair
d'abord tient est ce que ce projet qui a
été présenté aujourd'hui vous convient
ça ne l'est plus de questions que
j'obtiens réponses d'abord le coût du
projet quitte mais c'est pratiquement
deux fois plus que ce que coûte et tout
dernièrement le pont le plus achalandé
au canada qui le pont champlain
ça m'interpelle aussi que ce soit
présentée sous forme de projets de
transports collectifs alors que
essentiellement c'est pour permettre qui
est une facilité de circulation de
voitures de la rive-sud et la rive-nord
et inversement
alors ça m'interpelle que ce soit
présentée sous forme de projets
collectifs
ça me laisse aussi beaucoup de questions
sur l'aménagement avec des lois qui sont
autour
étant donné ce que ça offre une
opportunité de d'élargir beaucoup le
territoire d'habitation d'élargir le
périmètre d'urbanisation
ça m'interpelle j'ai beaucoup plus de
questions que de réponses aucun jeu car
je vis ce qu'on nous a présenté
aujourd'hui
questionne qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ben moi je pense plutôt comme le ministe
que c'est un 10 sur 10 en tout cas pour
l'intention qu'on exprime et de faire
finalement un troisième liés il n'y a
pas de doute dans mon esprit qu'un
troisième lien c'est requis à québec
et j'aime le fait qu'on ait intégré le
transport collectif les autobus
électriques le transport d'urgence
les dessertes pour le tramway et les
dessertes sur la rive-sud donc
l'intention est bien positionné et puis
surtout on rattache une ville de quand
même 250 mille personnes qui est lévy
qui est en croissance dynamique
c'est vrai ce que dit claire les coûts
sont importants mais il y aura deux ans
et demi d'études les considérations du
bape seront incluses
une expérience me disait
ce qu'on devrait penser à un pont
peut-être plutôt qu'un tunnel il faut
voir ces choses là c'est sûr que moins
d'impacts environnementaux avec un
tunnel et c'est quand même un projet qui
c'est qui qui va se payer ou qui voit
qu'il veut être rentabilisé sur une
centaine d'années voilà certaines c'est
ça ça me laisse beaucoup c'est tout ce
que ça implique parce qu'on privilégie
toujours la voiture la voiture
individuelle
c'est le projet au complet et créer
autour de l'utilisation de la voiture et
c'est ce qui m'interpelle le plus alors
que c'est une réflexion active qu'on
doit avoir sur l'étalement urbain sur
les la production de gaz est fixé à
effet de serre pardon sur l'ensemble de
considérer qu'ils doivent nous amener
vers la mobilité durable d'ailleurs
l'observatoire et durables ont aussi les
mêmes questions que celles que j'ai moi
c'est un peu ça questionne aussi la
question c'est oui la mobilité
certainement il faut améliorer la
mobilité mais de quelle façon
si on ajoute des voix qui viennent
encourager les gens à prendre davantage
l'automobile est ce qu ont atteint
l'objectif bien on encourage aussi de
transport collectif parce que si on n'a
pas de desserte pour lévis les gens ne
prendront pas le transport collectif ils
vont prendre leur voiture
les voies réservées sont prévues il faut
je pense qu'il faut voir une neuve qui
est intégrée dans l'offre qu'on aura au
global qui va faire que le transport
collectif va grandir et que la voiture
finalement on est au québec on n'est pas
à paris où il ya 5 millions de personnes
même à paris vous savez sur le
périphérique qui a quand même un million
de déplacements par jour alors on n'a
pas la même densité urbaine pendant des
solutions qui permettent qui nous
permettent de nous déplacer en étant
respectueux et l'environnement je vais
vous faire entendre le ministre des
transports françois bonnardel de nouveau
puis je vais vous faire réagir ensuite
le ministre j'entends les
environnementalistes nous dire ah ben ça
ne prend plus de voies réservées au
québec aujourd'hui il faut faire un
voyage de voix je ne ferai pas la guerre
aux automobilistes il n'y aura pas de
vol de voix on peut très bien utiliser
combiner un élargissement d'autoroute
pour être capable d'avoir des transports
collectifs et l'autre côté assurer une
meilleure fluidité des automobilistes
sur le réseau at il raison questionne
absolument parce que la fluidité c'est
important si on n'a de lien poncet quand
on était québec à l'heure de pointe les
bouchons on doit contourner selon alors
les émissions de gaz de serre il y en a
plus le plus longtemps on est sur la
route et je dirais que d'autre part il
faut penser qu'avec les gens qui
travaillent à domicile il ya une
augmentation très importance du fret
routier des marchandises les entrepôts
le commerce en ligne selon une étude de
roland berger ça va doubler d'ici 2050
alors on a besoin d'avoir des voies
routières qui sont adaptés et d'avoir
une offre de transport mais moi je
regarde c'est la vision du gouvernement
que je questionne actuellement milieu
municipal et dans un grand exercice est
la grande conversation sur l'urbanisme
et le développement des territoires où
le un des grands enjeux qui est traité
c'est justement la gestion de
l'urbanisation des milieux et on sait
que l'automobile favorise l'étalement
urbain
tout ce qui est des infrastructures
autoroutières favorise l'étalement
urbain en conséquence
moi j'aimerais comprendre la vision du
gouvernement c'est pour ça que j'ai
beaucoup plus de questions aujourd'hui
d'un côté on annonce des transports
collectifs pouvant aller jusqu'à 100
kilomètres de rayon autour de la
capitale d'un autre côté on réfléchi aux
conséquences de l'étalement urbain et
moi je pense simplement à l'aménagement
de la ville de québec où actuellement
c'est déjà un enjeu de trouver un
stationnement où les rues sont très
étroites et on ne peut pas
nécessairement des plastiques tous les
bâtiments de de part et d'autre de la
rue pour élargir la rue je réfléchis je
me demande moi quelle est la vision
verrière tout cet exercice là et j'ai
pas de réponse en ce moment et ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est que
l'étalement urbain fait partie d'eux
de l'enjeu que nous traitons cette
semaine la zone économie la frénésie
immobilière
on va présenter des reportages des
entrevues on va répondre aux questions
mais je veux vous entendre un
commentaire chacune là dessus est-ce
qu'il faut calmer cette frénésie
immobilière est ce que vous pensez que
l'état a un rôle à jouer
ou que le marché va s'auto calmer un
moment donné christiane avec t est ce
que le marché le marché va s'auto calmer
parce que les achats seront financés et
on a une agence au canada qui s'appelle
la schl aux étés canadienne
d'hypothèques et de logement qui dans le
passé quand il ya des crises
immobilières très très très bien réagi
et très près de la banque du canada
parce qu'on sait bien que si on achète
une maison peu les plus chers des taux
d'intérêt et si le taux d'intérêt non ça
va être plus difficile mais je pense
qu'on une concertation qui est
excellente
par contre comme on a discuté il ya
quelques semaines de mieux réglementer
le marché du courtage immobilier de
faire en sorte que les propositions
soient transparentes et ouvertes ça ça
m'apparaît très important alors pour
l'instant je n'interviendrai pas ok
parfait clair je suis plutôt inquiète
mois sur l'accessibilité sur les
logements accessibles et les propriétés
accessible pour la population et c'est
le monsieur côté guaino tout à l'heure
mentionnée votre éviter mentionné que
les populations vont de plus en plus
loin pour trouver une propriété à coût
abordable
moi ça m'interpelle et je me suis gay ce
qu'on a vu à vancouver à toronto
ce sont des éléments qui devraient ainsi
l'accessibilité des propriétés qui était
inquiétant c'est aussi la gentrification
de certains milieux qui amène qui
déplace les populations et qui amène la
perte de la perte de cultures locales
l'endroit locaux pour les populations
mais le problème est réglé le troisième
billet va tout régler
c'est triste ok merci beaucoup mais un
bonheur
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit